[Applaudissements]
je vais vous parler du changement de
civilisation dont personne ne parle
parce que le changement de civilisation
c'est comme les sbires qui sidère il n'y
a qu'une toute petite partie qui est
visible tout le reste est sous l'eau et
je vais commencer par tout en bas dans
le froid et je commence par une mauvaise
nouvelle
notre civilisation a inventé deux
manières de se suicider 1 la guerre
nucléaire
nous sommes passés de 34 fois à 17 fois
la possibilité de faire sauter la terre
ces dix-sept fois de trop évidemment et
puis il ya une deuxième manière un dogme
bizarre le dôme de la croissance infinie
dans un monde fini c'est évidemment
suicidaire oui nous sommes tous deux
dans tous les jours et on n'en parle pas
c'est en bas maintenant je suis désolé
je vais vous dire quelque chose de
positif
je sais que ce n'est pas très à la mode
mais si on rencontre le citoyen dans la
rue les rues de new york
dwan aux airs moscou paris bruxelles on
se rend compte que le citoyen mais il
veut un avenir pour ses enfants et ses
petits-enfants et donc qu'est-ce qui est
en train de se passer
eh bien il ya un changement des valeurs
de base de la civilisation on est en
train de passer de valeur de mort à des
valeurs de vie et ce moteur parce que
c'est le moteur du changement
ce moteur personne ne peut
arrêté comme disait très bien willis
harman qui a un vécu en californie à 20
ans du mandement du temps où la
californie
réfléchissez intelligemment il disait
personne personne aucune force politique
économique ou militaire ne peut arrêter
ce changement qui se passe au niveau le
plus profond de chaque citoyen nous
sommes dans un moteur qui pousse le
changement de civilisation et qui pousse
tous les autres niveaux
alors il est temps de parler déjà du
second niveau
le second niveau c'est que le patriarcat
est en crise pourquoi mais parce que les
valeurs ccc command control conquête qui
sont très utiles pour aller jusqu'à la
lune ne sont pas suffisantes pour aller
vers un monde se tape il faut d'autres
valeurs qu'il faut ajouter des valeurs
plus en plus féminine et donc ce gros
tank cruel qui continue à écraser
quelques millions de femmes par jour
le moteur du tank est en crise et nous
allons vers une civilisation post
patriarcale où il faudra réinventer le
rôle de l'homme le rôle de la femme le
rôle la famille évidemment et ce n'est
pas tout nous avons mesuré à la
commission européenne mais aussi aux
états unis nous avons mesuré qu'il y a
de par le monde au moins un milliard de
gens donc en chine dans l'islam un peu
partout qui sont en train de changer de
valeur en silence un milliard ça fait
pas mal
et ça fait tellement que les 60 ce n'est
les 80 % de gens qui ne sont pas dans le
changement commence à se gratter la tête
et ne pas comprendre ce qui se passe
parce que personne n'en parle
et qu'est ce qu'ils font ils votent pour
troupes ils votent pour des leaders de
droite qui leur disent avec moi pas de
changement on continue comme avant
illusion le numéro 3 le niveau 3 c'est
le niveau du trans moderne
nous allons changer la manière de
concevoir le réel dans nos universités
notamment avec les neurosciences mais
avec tout un ensemble c'est la manière
même de penser le réel qui est en train
de se transformer dans les laboratoires
un petit peu en dehors de l'université
et une seconde bonne nouvelle c'est que
le trans moderne c'est le retour de
l'éthique et du sens il faut que ça
fasse sens
or aujourd'hui notre civilisation
industrielle ne fait plus sens elles
continuent elles continuent elles
continuent jusqu'au moment où elles
risquent de passer en dessous deux
autres plaques tectoniques immatériel
trans moderne post patriarcale le
passage mais il faut faire attention et
nous sommes des milliers dans le tedx
notamment à essayer et à travailler pour
que ce passage se fasse le plus
doucement possible
alors maintenant nous sommes au niveau 4
juste en dessous de l'eau on n'en parle
pas mais les gens commencent à à se dire
peut-être que quand même cette économie
matériel sert peu différent alors je
vous raconte une petite histoire
donc j'étais membre de la cellule de
prospective de la commission européenne
un think tank créé par jacques delors du
temps on réfléchissait à la commission
européenne ce temps être à exister et
jacques delors nous d'y aller
faites moi une étude vous avez six mois
fait moyenne et tout sur l'économie
européenne en 2030
bon nous on travaille en réseau avec des
économistes du monde entier
on travaille on travaille on travaille
on arrive on fait un livre blanc on le
traduit en français en anglais en
allemand en fin dans toutes les langues
et jacques delors tout fier arrive chez
les chefs d'état en décembre 90 93 au
conseil des chefs d'état
j'allais dire 93 mais bon et il présente
son livre c'est la catastrophe
c'est la carte se trouve pourquoi parce
que les chefs d'état ont dit mais mais
mais mais on pas dit comme ça mais on
sait rien faire avec ça tu changement de
civilisation on sait rien faire
changement de paradigme on sait rien
faire et donc ça fait ça fait 30 ans
presque trente ans qu'on souhaitait que
le politique se tait au niveau du
changement
je ne les condamne pas je comprends je
ne dis pas que j'approuve
mais je comprends parce que c'est très
difficile à vendre et le premier
politicien qui dit si vous votez pour
moi on change de paradigme
et donc le cinquième niveau et la
transformation du politique
la transformation du politique vient
d'en bas et je voudrais ajouter ceci les
enjeux du 21e siècle sont rois la
maîtrise le contrôle politique de
l'économie mondiale le contrôle
politique de la science et contrôle
éthique de la science et le contrôle
éthique de la technologie ça veut dire
que nous aussi nous devons élever notre
niveau éthique de conscience et poussé
la venue le surgissement de politiciens
nouveaux qui seront un petit peu comme
ce que platon imaginer une juste trois
mille ans il disait
et si les philosophes s'occuper un peu
de politique
et si les politiciens étaient en même
temps des philosophes c'est à dire
qu'ils cheminent intérieurement vers le
chemin de l'être
eh bien nous allons vers cette époque où
nous allons créer des politiciens qui
nous aideront et qui catalyse rond cette
réflexion est sûre c'est repenser et de
la civilisation mondiale
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]